when they weren't arguing who's a bigger
racist Democrats meant that debate
tonight explaining why a socialist
shouldn't be there 2020 nominee they
worried it might lead to this if you
keep on going we will elect Bernie
Bernie will lose to Donald Trump and
Donald Trump and the House and the
Senate and some of the state houses will
all go red if we cannot pull this party
together if we go to one of those
extremes we take a terrible risk of
reelecting Donald Trump not only is this
a way to get Donald Trump reelected and
they're all raising their hand all the
time it's class time joining me now Ari
Fleischer from a White House press
secretary Fox News contributor along
with Chris Hahn former aide to Senator
Chuck Schumer hosted the aggressive
progressive podcast and pollster Frank
Luntz Ari your big takeaway tonight you
watched well my big takeaway from a
democratic point of view is that they
survived
nobody really bombed this time Bloomberg
bombed last time you didn't bomb this
time so he's kind of saving himself two
fights over Super Tuesday actually did
decently he came across as somewhat
articulate somewhat with energy it was a
different Joe Biden tonight which is
huge for him on the eve of South
Carolina but face of Laura it's a
three-way race it's Bernie Bloomberg and
Sanders when you look at the way this is
going Chris now doesn't it seem that
after New Hampshire it became fairly
clear who the three were going to be I
mean Ari's right it's down to those
three Tom Steyer is just blathering up
there and you know Klobuchar you know
she was very intent on what she was
saying and Budaj edge tried to be very
earnest and but none of those guys are
you know the people are gonna be
President so they're just making it more
likely that Bernie becomes the ultimate
nominee I'm that's I'm gonna stick to
what I said weeks ago on this that if
you don't drop out and coalesce but
something behind one alternative to
Bernie Birdy's gonna run away with this
is be over by you know the first week
second week of March so yeah I mean
Bernie is definitely in the driver's
seat I agree with you on that however
what Biden did tonight might help him he
took a nice attack on steyr on the
private prison investment and if he
could back that up with ads
that could cut into what's tire has done
to him in South Carolina if you look at
the polls in South Carolina he's not
really losing ground because Bernie's
gaining ground he lost a lot of ground
to steyr who's made an overwhelming
investment in South Carolina as his last
stand State so what Biden did tonight
was very strategic he had a good debate
and who knows maybe this can help him
have a bigger margin of victory on
Saturday in South Carolina and propel
him into Super Tuesday as a real
contender I just loved how Biden did
everything in the Obama administration
it was basically all his idea all night
long it was like well but I did that
over octave it was hilarious
I don't think Barack probably gave him
much except girl-scout pinning
ceremonies or something I don't know
what he gave Biden footage he took
credit for all of it all right Frank I
do think there is one weakness that was
exhibited from Bernie Sanders tonight
and this is how he tripled down on it
watch Cuba made progress on education
yes I think really really great progress
on health care that was Barack Obama
America has overthrown governments all
over the world when dictatorships
whether it is the Chinese or the Cubans
do something good you acknowledge that
in Hamas builds all those schools Frank
where else does this hurt Bernie beyond
Florida well you're right because three
times tonight Bernie was booed and he
clearly got angry with it he started
challenging the audience and in fact
this is the secret recipe for the other
candidates they put people supporters in
the audience to challenge Sanders when
he makes statements like that and it
rattles him we've never seen that before
the other key for Sanders is that he has
to in some of these states Super Tuesday
States Republicans and independents can
vote in the Democratic primary they're
open Sanders is going to have a
tremendous problem getting anyone who
isn't far left so watch they're going to
be surprised in some of these polls
where Bloomberg I think is going to win
some Super Tuesday States and I agree
with Ari
tonight Mike blue
did much better than he did the last
time the first half-hour debate was to
beat the crap out of him he survived
that and he even ended very strongly
yeah but singing improved from the first
debate I mean that's why I don't know
what the comparison yeah I mean I would
hope so my goodness it was pathetic so
he actually stood up and spoke and and
defended his record in in New York and
the big gulps and all that and talked
about how we have too many fat people he
said basically said that again tonight
but I don't know I don't think there's a
country as clamoring for Bloomberg I
just don't see the Bloomberg thing I'm
gonna stick to what I keep saying is
Bernie's unless something weird happened
to go ahead Chris you know Laura you
know politics is about expectations and
and he had very low expectations for
this debate so he clearly cleared that
bar tonight so we'll see what happens
this is the last debate before Super
Tuesday and as for Biden taking credit
we've all worked for elected officials
that's what they do they are to take
credit for everything well is he gay or
not yeah because Ari said that Biden did
a great job and you're being your
sorries just such a nice person and I
think we've all felt bad for Biden over
the last few days especially when he
said he was running for Senate but he
also said this tonight which raised some
eyebrows watch a hundred and fifty
million people have been killed since
2007 when Bernie voted to exempt the gun
manufacturers from liability more than
all the wars including Vietnam from that
point on carnage on our street three
hundred and fifty thousand mostly
suicides with guns that's a big that's
half the countries have a gun yeah I'm
not going outside the studio tonight
there's carnage on the streets I'm
afraid to go out but at some point
doesn't his family or friends Sabre in
Joe you've had an incredible career but
this that moment passed
he had that chance and he decided to run
for president but I'll forgive him of
that that's just a blooper every
politician makes a numbers mistake
something like that by this issue though
is that's been his whole persona the
entire campaign until tonight and on the
eve of South Carolina when he needs that
win just to stay in the race I think he
saved his campaign
for South Carolina if he does a good
race in South Carolina he lives to fight
on Super Tuesday without any money
though and that'll be his problem
all right Frank there was a moment when
Bernie was talking about the economy and
how it works for just a small sliver of
people watch the economy is doing really
great for people like mr. Bloomberg and
other billionaires but the ordinary
American things are not so good last
year real wage increases for the average
worker with less than 1% half of our
people are living paycheck to paycheck
that is not an economy that's working
for the American people
Frank does that work the economy is not
working there's a better question than
that and it's a question are you better
off today than you were four years ago
sixty-one percent of Americans an
all-time high
say yes they've been asking that
question since 1980 it's never been
higher than that what Bernie Sanders
doesn't understand is that the average
American not only is better off today
than they were four years ago
but they're expecting the economy and
their own situation to improve he's
making a big mistake and really the only
winner tonight and you know I've been
occasionally critical the winner tonight
is Donald Trump because what the
American people saw is chaos they were
they were tearing each other apart they
could not control each other and the
public doesn't not want that not only
the Democrats but the general public
does not want that yeah I wish we had
time to talk about how the moderators
did because that was an interesting
approach it was kind of just they were
horrible no III mean it has nothing
personal it's probably hard to do that
I've not done that except with you guys
and you guys are pretty you follow the
rules pretty well but when people just
don't stop talking it is a difficult
situation plural Biden woke up saying
nobody respects me like he kept saying
nobody respects a nice gentleman which
they also they never asked Biden about
his getting arrest in the South Africa
they missed an opportunity to actually
ask a real question all right you guys
see I can control this kind of putting
statements in these debates maybe get
off maybe slow roll it you know yeah and
by the way we all know that four back
attack
therefore pot legalization okay we all
know that we didn't have to spend five
or ten minutes on that subject so I'm
not sure why that was brought up
all right gentlemen thanks so much and